the new beyond light expansion provides
more of what destiny 2 is good at
satisfying first-person shooting
fascinating places to explore
a whole lot of pungy guns to try out and
a great inventive raid
it also maintains some of the game's
lingering problems though like a
reliance on repetitive content and
time-sucking grinds to arbitrarily raise
numbers
to put it simply beyond light is largely
more destiny
if that's a thing you like you'll enjoy
it and if it's a thing you complain
about you probably won't
the last two years have seen bungie
making changes to destiny 2
both large and incremental that are
improving the game deepening its world
and expanding its experiences
beyond light is perhaps the best told
story that developer bungie has put
forth in the game
the focus is on characters who have
feelings and motivations which allows
them to grow beyond being just voices on
the radio
yelling at you to go shoot another world
threatening alien
and new additions to the game like a
host of freezing abilities called stasis
change up the gameplay and combat
strategies in fun and unexpected ways
the new expansion takes you to europa
one of jupiter's frozen moons to uncover
secrets about the latest threat invading
the solar system
the darkness for the last few seasons of
destiny 2
we've been puzzling out what the
darkness has in store for us but instead
of attacking
the darkness is offering seductive power
it doesn't want to kill the guardian
heroes that players control
it wants to own them
you answered we've kept you waiting long
enough
come to us salvation awaits
much of the story of beyond light is
about characters trying to figure out
how to harness the powers offered by the
darkness
called stasis in order to fight it but
the most pressing threat
is aramis a member of the alien race
known as the fallen
who has gotten hold of stasis and is
raising an army to wield it
taking her out is your goal for the
first few hours of the expansion
but that's mostly a vehicle to getting
stasis into your hands
so you can run wild with it
stasis is the real star of beyond light
offering a new brand of abilities that
require you to rethink your strategies
the powers of stasis debuff enemies
slowing them down
freezing them solid or walling them off
behind giant ice crystals
where most abilities and supers in
destiny 2 are dedicated to damaging
enemies or healing teammates
stasis adds capabilities for controlling
the battlefield
changing the landscape and altering the
odds these powers are a nice refresher
for guardian capabilities
and feel significantly different from
everything else already available
the icy approach of stasis requires you
to figure out how to best use it against
enemies
and how to best avoid getting frozen by
opponents as stasis becomes a more
regular part of destiny 2
it's easy to imagine ways it can be
paired with existing abilities and
weapons
to pave the way for a whole new set of
tactics stasis also comes with a bunch
of customizations you can earn as you
play
amping up the effectiveness of some
elements of your new capabilities while
exacting tolls like drops and character
stats
destiny 2 has come a long way in
providing ways to spec out your
characters
and stasis deepens that system with
additional satisfying choices
however a lot of beyond light is destiny
as usual
the quest to get your new stasis powers
for instance often consists of the usual
shoot x number of y enemy grind there
also continues to be a heavy reliance on
bounties which require completing
minor objectives that are mostly about
racking up kills with specific weapons
or abilities
and which can be boring to slog through
especially when it slows you down from
accessing cool new stasis elements
but while some of the gameplay can be
predictable europa is an impressive new
offering
it's a big location with varied
environments to explore
including frozen wastes ravaged ruins a
fallen city
and huge sci-fi facilities the
destination also adds dynamic weather to
destiny 2 for the first time
and while it's not a drastic change a
blizzard whipping up in the middle of a
firefight to kill visibility
forces you to change how you play just
enough to make europa
dangerous and unstable bungie has also
gone
much further in developing the story you
uncover along the way through the
expansion
the battle against airmass is mixed up
with varrix an old destiny 1 character
and deals with their disagreement on how
best to serve and protect the scattered
fallen race
it was never meant to be an empire
it was meant to be home
finding and harnessing stasis expands
the story of the exo stranger
another destiny 1 character and finally
sheds light on a bunch of questions that
have lingered since the confusing
destiny one campaign
i once asked guardians to destroy the
black heart
to prevent darkness's arrival
success may have been achieved but i now
know that fake comes knocking sooner or
later
this expansion tells a coherent story
that's grounded in interactions between
characters you've spent lots of time
with over the years
you don't have to have read a ton of
lore to understand what's going on in
beyond light but the storytelling will
make you want to do so and reward you
with additional nuance for the
investment
we've also seen a little bit of new
content for the ongoing season of the
hunt
which centers on aldrin saav they call
me
the crow my
boss wants to see you he's the guy
players hunted down to exact revenge on
for the murder of k-6 in the forsaken
expansion
aldrin has been revived as a guardian
losing the memories of his past life and
misdeeds in the process
this season he sends you on brief but
engaging boss hunts
to earn specific perk and stat rules on
new gear while this season
like others will mostly consist of
replaying the same activities to chase
various guns and armor
the simmering conflict of working
closely with a guy your character
executed makes the season of the hunt
feel like it's burgeoning with
possibilities
the character implications of the season
already provide as big a draw to that
content as the endless loot chase
even after six years though there are
still growing pains with beyond light
and destiny 2 at large bungie has
removed a lot of content from destiny 2
with this expansion
several destinations and activities have
been vaulted with a possibility that
they
could be re-released sometime in the
future europa is a big place
but it's true that there's altogether
less of destiny 2 than there was a year
ago
that's not necessarily all bad the game
was getting unwieldy
big chunks of it were barely visited by
players and just because you could
unlock and use hundreds of guns
didn't mean they were all worth the
effort but for a game that is both
built on and hampered by repetition less
content means less variety and that
means things can get stale
all the quicker but this is also the
most alive destiny 2
has felt at least since the best days of
the forsaken expansion
and maybe ever this is the closest we've
ever been to its story characters and
lore
and the most we've ever seen characters
interacting with each other in
meaningful ways
already we've uncovered a bunch of deep
cut fascinating story beats about
characters who have persisted in destiny
since the beginning
and the deep stone crypt raid is an
exciting intense and inventive challenge
and completing it altered europa in some
significant ways
beyond light might not be the biggest
destiny expansion but it does feel like
we've entered a new chapter in the
game's life
with new priorities and an approach that
makes the game more resonant beyond
satisfying shooting
on the whole destiny 2 may be more same
than it is different
but what's the same like it's phenomenal
raids and tight satisfying gameplay
is still pretty great and what's
different is making the game all the
more worthwhile
you